hello so this behind me is my wall of
stuff most of it is stuff that I've
collected myself but some of it is stuff
that people have posted to me and some
stuff that my friends have done as well
however I have recently reached a
milestone in my life whereby I've
decided that I want to move out and
seeing as I'm leaving this bedroom
unfortunately the wall of stuff is going
to have to leave with me so um let's
take down the wall huh a Doctor Who card
that my sister got for me showing off my
Apple love first year at secondary
school
an article about hating Twilight from my
friend Patrick Patrick with a cake on
his face post-it notes from Lex and Alex
hostess from miles Becky and Tom my
renetto mask
Ljuba cool bit everybody doing it
Charlie McDonnell through the ages
Christmas card from a friend Tom or a
meaningless traditions card look at that
is it dad Amy Mario gigabytes the pig
that my friend Alex had a relationship
with donor then uh that's a my head on
Bella from Twilight's body MetroCard
from New York New York City from back
when I wanted to be a rockstar just
don't blink
I said don't blink but did you know that
the image of an angel is itself an angel
oh yeah just in case you were wondering
from when I went to watch watch one
uh-oh
well these were some stickers but I kind
of destroyed them a little poster from
my mum a hamlet flyer signed by David
Tennant's Caitlin Hill Emma so business
cards an old Oyster card my father hello
go team cool like that's me they're
naked on a pointy there's another one of
those somewhere where you can see my
whole jangling bits but him I won't look
at a picture of a strange boy random
snowman just some of my train tickets
hey I'm Edward Cullen hey I'm Charlie
McDonnell this is the origin story of my
mole Wally look at that gap look at it a
picture from the person called puja a
note from Merriman I actually made this
as a Christmas present for a girl I was
dating at the time but we broke up
before Christmas so I never got the
chance to give it to her fail a little
t-shirt that was given to me when I was
in San Diego Oh take it to San Francisco
and a doctor horrible flyer a flyer
that's now kind of been destroyed down
here but no worries Pokemon guards one
win that I won at Funland a chant
Decker's heart and the sticker that says
yay char Jagger's poster a happy son
more business cards some googly eyes my
sister got me this car because
reminded her of Super Mario Galaxy visit
two passes from the times I've been to
the BBC you can see the bottom it says
please return this badge to reception
yeah no thanks a birthday card for the
people who made the chartjackers team is
hat do you like raisins
Yoshi a pretty powerful looking you year
card
I guess Alex gave this to me I have no
idea I take it to see district 9 1 for
the invention of lying a meerkat card
that my mum got me from when I went to
see tank bats please don't ask me why I
went to go and see teh that a Disney
Store tank the tank is actually from
this Finding Nemo turtle which was a
present that I bought for a girl while I
was dating here and then I broke up with
her before I got a chance to give it to
her Dec a recurring theme I do
all praise are bountiful Overlord Google
praise be to the googly Lord what to be
missed and there a mom dftba records
sticker not much left starbursts record
the flyer from the charge a cos gig
that's my favorite bit my wristband from
when I went to e3 the last of the
business cards a free sugar doughnut
that I never ate zombies are people to
me is a little toddler wine gums Doctor
Who hey a scary scary gun my ticket for
when I went to see tape that a postcard
of a ball a business cards my mum didn't
used to know how to copy and paste so
she would write the link out by hand and
then type it in afterwards from when I
did the my crib video a sign we use when
we did the challenge of his auditions
obviously this is a drawing of me by
Nathan y burn and um that's it that's
why uh-oh
I guess it's gone forever or is it yes
it is you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
oh man oh man